what happened last night uh it was not
last night it was like few days ago my
boyfriend like got in the prison so when
another guy like I we were staying on
the beach so and everybody like saw us
that he got into jail and everybody knew
that I'm by myself another guy came like
in my [ __ ] tent and [ __ ] raped me
and after like just the guys from the
beach bit him like so badly he almost
died
and that's why police came and took like
my tent and everything like
all my clothes everything is gone
you've been here from the Ukraine for
how how long you've been here like eight
years yes it's going to be like yeah in
October eight years
you've been staying where
I was like I came to New York I came
with like my with my husband
so and after like just we broke up
I started to work in like as a stripper
like in a club
um starting to do like a lot of drugs
lost my apartment
after I moved to Miami I was like just
living in Miami for two years after back
in New York and it was like just more or
less okay so I have like a few
businesses
and after coronavirus start and some guy
pushed me under the train you see I have
like a metal leg
oh wow yeah I'm just like accidentally
alive
after that I start like to be like all
the time on the Xanax because like I
have like the [ __ ] horrible panic
attacks
United States has been rough year no you
the United States has been rough for you
yeah
Ella like really rough following you so
you came from Miami to Los Angeles I
mean no I came like from Miami I just
like was living staying in Miami and I'm
back like to New York and after New York
I came here you've been L.A how long in
Los Angeles I came in May
like just all summer
like three or four months what is your
drug now what is your drug now
I'm just like I like I'm doing crack
so that's not my favorite
what's your favorite acid
and I love cocaine but right now it's
like so difficult to find like any game
you know like just everything mixed with
spit and all yeah yeah so like just I
don't really like masses make me like
crazy like
ruin my brain but like
like the best that you can find is
[ __ ] Chris
so yeah
how do you support yourself how do you
make money
I'm doing painting
painting what well I'm just painting I'm
artist I'm selling my art oh you are
yeah like just like that's what I say
like just when the police came and like
grabbed my tent like it was like so many
painting I was selling it on the beach
so right now I don't have like any
supplies nothing I have to like do
something with this
and my boyfriend like in prison
I'm just by myself
so they put him in jail mm-hmm I mean
like he was like in prison for four
years so he was like stealing car and
like guns he's still like 15 [ __ ]
guns oh wow
and his friend like just called the
police you know like the police came
like and like arrested him so he spent
like four years in jail in a prison I
mean and he was like on parole I don't
know if they're gonna if they can like
just you know like back him into prison
nobody know like he has like Court like
on 21st
how's this lifestyle get to you
emotionally
what do you mean does it affect you
emotionally to be living on the streets
like this of course
I mean I always have you'll see like
this I just like got in the street just
because of this guy because of my
boyfriend I always have like the sugar
lady you know I didn't I mean I had like
two apartments in New York I still have
one like in Brooklyn
but
I mean it's love
and he's crazy
he lost his wallet with all documents
somebody robbed me you know like just
like my documents is gone I was waiting
like for like almost two months to like
to restore my like New York
a license
so
yeah
and we was like fighting all the time
like doing like a lot of drugs so it's
like everything is affected
do you regret coming to the United
States do you regret coming to the U.S
from Ukraine not at all
it's much better here okay
I mean yeah tell me about living in you
you're growing up you grew up you grew
up there I grew up like by the way in
Belarus
I was born over there after my family
moved back to Ukraine so and like
um
it's horrible like political situation
you know like it's corruption everywhere
so like just
and I have like not a really like happy
family you know
my mom just like my like real father he
left my mom when she was pregnant so I
was like growing up with stepfather who
was like raping him up like
all my childhood that's why I was like
run away from the house you know like
just when I was 14. oh you're you're
being molested are you step dad
so yeah
and my mom like you know like she just
close eyes for this so
so your childhood is very rough yeah it
was really rough
I was like just by myself you know like
just
because like it was like in Soviet Union
I was born like over there and like when
the woman pregnant and she just like by
herself you know like just it's not easy
everybody like just
if she was like just fired from her job
you know because like you know a
behavior was not really moral you know
like all her firm like my family started
to hate her like and me too you know so
and she just like all the time blamed me
that I just like ruined her life but
like you say
so do you do you feel like you have any
family now
I don't have family at all
um I'm just like my sister not really
like communicate with me so
my mom I don't I mean she's calling me
asking me about like how am I you know
like but
my family has money you know but they
never like helped me with that
I'm just by myself
what is your biggest problem though is
it the drug addiction
I'm I can I'm just like alcoholic to be
honest I'm not like drug addicted I
couldn't be without the drugs you know
I'm doing it like because like
it's like time like just going much
faster you know so alcohol is really
alcohol is my problem but I mean I have
like pestidity after like I got like
under the train you know I had like just
a panic disorder you know like just what
happened on the train like the guy
pushed me under the train in New York in
New York in Subway yeah that's why I
moved from New York because I I couldn't
use like the subway you know anymore
like it scared me like just even like
when I just like hear like the voice
noise of train you know because I was
almost dead
I just was like I'm just honestly I'm
just super lucky that I'm just alive
and like just the doctor when I got like
this actually you see it's like
completely mashed that's it's all metal
really yeah it's like the you see like
this is a metal leg you walk fine I mean
like the doctors nobody like even
couldn't say me if I can walk or not
I was like spent like six months like in
hospital
and just because like one junkie guy
decided like to push me under the train
I even didn't know this dude you know
you just just random I just like I yeah
I was supposed to go like to Vacation
like in Atlanta to visit my friends so
and like I was staying waiting like
Subway and headphones you know and he
just like he was on drugs I think or
whatever you know and he just like
pushed me and like I felt like on a
running train you know like
and I was like almost melted I was like
felling down with the train you know and
I just already see like how my head you
know melted between train and like the
platform and
I was thinking I was almost like ready
to die and after I didn't realize like
just goddamn I never gonna see Las Vegas
again that's my favorite city and I
pushed my legs you know between like the
train and platform and it saved my life
it's ruined my leg but it saved my life
wow
so and I was lucky I guess like just uh
to the hospital and it was like the
shift of really like famous like
Professor you know like just his like
Orthopedic genius you know and even he
didn't know like if I can walk or not
like my first surgery was like 10 hours
your leg looks perfect your leg looks
almost perfect yeah I mean like but you
know like and you walk perfectly
yeah but it's just like it was crazy
nobody believed that they can walk again
they're going through stuff like that
would make you drink going through
something like that would make one drink
yeah
I mean I started drinking like because
of my ex-boyfriend
he pushed me like in a strip club you
know
and when I was like working in a strip
club it's like drugs everywhere you know
like just and when you're on the drugs
you're just like drinking like because
like to calm down like after this
so and it was like this like just you
doing like just the cane after you just
like drinking after you're doing Xanax
to fell asleep
and like this became a routine and I was
like this like four years ago and it was
like a big money but like you anyway
spending is like for nothing
how bad is your drinking how bad does
your drinking get
when I'm not like
um you know when I'm not
emotional I mean how to say like when
I'm not stressed out
I just not drink a lot I can like drink
like just probably a bottle of wine in a
day you know like but when I'm stressed
out I can drink nine bottles of wine in
one day in one day
I'm drinking Non-Stop and it's like even
don't make me like just you know like
drunk
I just keep me like just normal
song
how old are you oh how old am I 33 Jesus
Christ is
no children no I wish but I can't
you can't I can't have a children
I have like just problems
but I love children my sister has the
nephew you know like this
I never see him like a life just like
just on the Skype
so yeah what would you like to do with
your life I mean listen when I was like
in New York
like first of all I need like just to
calm down because like I couldn't like
concentrate on nothing when I'm just
like stressed out you know
I need like just apartment
so
I'm like I I want to do some business
I had like two businesses in New York
just my first business it was like just
a bakery
uh me and like four of my friends food
was like just create like the bakery
like
me and my first like second husband I
moved here you know it was like cake
artist
so
I was doing like customer cakes
and the second business it was digital
marketing agency because I'm just like
doing web web design you know like
social
Media stuff
and yeah and also I'm doing painting
it's like before the coronaviruses was
like so cool I was doing like the art
party you know like I had like a lot of
collectors I mean I still have but I'm
just like procrastinate too much like
just during like all this pandemic you
know and I didn't do really nothing
so I just
I want to be back in art
foreign
do you have friends I mean
not really
just the last I just had a friend you
know like just it doesn't happen like my
boyfriend got into prison
I had like just a friend
but I [ __ ] with her boyfriend so right
now we're not friends anymore yeah
that'll hurt a friendship I'm bad in a
friend who is the friend
I don't know how to like just
how to be a friend did you blame the
crack no I blend myself like this and
that's me this is you yeah well
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
I think so yeah
I mean and you know what like this funny
yeah like I didn't distract myself a lot
but in the it's like just the waves you
know because I'm bipolar you know like
just I can be like just okay and like
successful and everything like for some
time and after I just like push myself
down you know so so badly and like yeah
I
it's like
I don't know it's like hard to explain
you self-sabotage yeah
you feel like you don't deserve to be
successful or happy
sometimes yes because I read a lot of
[ __ ] in my life
but like that's what I say like it's
like just a different state of mind like
you know like just when I up like for
example
I just like I decided I'm just like
thinking they deserve everything you
know like the best that can happen but
when I just like down
I'm just hate myself you know and I'm
just like
I feel myself like piece of [ __ ] like
something like this
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently nothing
I mean I love myself I mean I distract
myself but in the same time I know like
everything that I did you know like make
me the person who I am right now well
I'm just everything that happened
like even like just when I got like
under the train you know it's like
changed me like it's
like it showed me like completely
different different like world you know
like you when you see like death in the
face it's like
I mean you never became like just
the person who he was before
did you have role models are you a kid
did you have role models in your life
when you were a kid
I don't know the owner that I was I
remember that I
I was like just hate to be like the
similar that my parents you know like
just
I never like want to be like them that's
it I like hate everything that was like
just connected for that so you know like
I just like tried to change my hair
color like because we me and my mom you
know we have like just real really
really similar like features you know
like almost the same face and I hated
like all my life you know I just was
changing like just since I started like
to be like just 12 or something you know
just like I put a lot of piercing in
myself you know just change like the
hair you know like to be like completely
different
it was not like just any model you know
like the or someone like who I want to
be like but I just the only that I know
that I don't want to be like these
people that's you know
what are you afraid of
hot and spiders
and pain
and trains and trains
I mean like where do I when I got under
the trains I didn't feel any pain
that's the adrenaline though um that's
the adrenaline yeah my leg was
completely you know meshed I just like
remember how I was laying down in like
just all these cars it's like open
fractures you know like my jeans was
raped like and Bones was like just
around but I was feeling myself like
that I'm like on cocaine you know just
like I was so up I didn't lost the
Consciousness nothing you know and just
the paramedic was like just try to get
me you know like and I was like just
talking with him with them like smiling
like crazy
I I came to the hospital I fill out all
the forms you know by myself like always
like just a smash legs I didn't feel
nothing until like just after the
surgery I just like got unconsciousness
and death was [ __ ] freaking pain
I was like just they give me like they
loaded morphine oxycodone all three of
them together you know
and it was like six months like this
and after it like the leg was swollen
like for like just probably eight months
I couldn't like walk normally I supposed
to like use the crunches but I came like
at the hospital and asked my roommate
like I said like just [ __ ] the crunches
like go and buy me like sneakers you
know he bought me like sneakers and I
just like buy the flight to Las Vegas I
can a few days and like just it was like
stopped in in Ohio I think you know and
I realized stuff for two hours and I
realized that my leg is completely
swollen and just what the [ __ ] I'm doing
like
I don't supposed to go there and after
that like I got like in the jail there
always my broken leg
so yeah
it was crazy what's your favorite
quality about yourself
quality
um my favorite
I'm smart
and the same status like time I'm super
stupid
no
but I like to analyze everything you
know what's going on around me I have
like a critical thinking I think
I have like my master's degree
in fine art
so
Sasha what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important
in my life yeah it's the most important
thing you've learned in life
I don't know honestly like just probably
like just to see the beauty
you know
like beauty is important yeah absolutely
no
all right Sasha thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
lots of luck thank you you're on the
streets thank you thank you hopefully I
get out from the streets